[Musica]
giro
veloce del romitino ma anche se spero
sarei vaccinato ormai rotti facciamoci
ha già immunizzata nel presente ok
successo serio come sai bene domenica
piacere vederti qui a mestre grazie per
essere venuta per il tuo bellissimo talk
ci hai parlato di suardi differenze di
inclusività sai che oggi abbiamo questa
grande staffetta fra oltre 24 tedeschi
italiani che parlano di democrazia
digitale e ti chiedo subito ma secondo
te il digitale e il suo linguaggio
è democratico
allora dipende dal punto di vista nel
senso sicuramente come è già stato detto
peraltro il digitale può aiutare in
molti casi ha intanto far sentire le
voci di colore che prima non avevano la
voce
ancora fino a direi fino a 15 20 anni fa
chi è che aveva una voce pubblica
qualcuno che aveva un motivo per essere
già un personaggio pubblico quindi un
politico non solo intellettuale
vip in generale e se ci pensate al loro
detenevano in assoluto il
condominio della parola pubblica quand'è
che spuntava una voce diciamo non
conosciuta preciso rastatt e dagli
esperimenti interessanti che hanno fatto
storia per esempio quando radio radicale
a un certo punto apre i microfoni e
scopre un lato b quasi dell'italia degli
italiani e dell'italiano che prima non
era così noto più dio le persone parlano
davvero così oppure quando non so in
qualche telegiornale si dà al microfono
alle persone per strada grandi norma la
voce pubblica era di pochi era
un'aristocrazia diciamo così cosa ha
fatto la rete e soprattutto i social
effettivamente ha dato voce a chi prima
una voce non ce l'aveva poi ovvio sui
grandi numeri ci sono molti che la usano
così così alcuni che la usano davvero
male ma per fare l'in vale e alcuni che
invece ci fanno delle cose francamente
molto interessanti per esempio beh
vediamo le giovani generazioni che fanno
delle cose che io alla loro età non
avrei potuto fare quindi da questo punto
di vista la rete ed i social soprattutto
sicuramente hanno un effetto
democratizzante però è vero che poi c'è
un altro tipo di divario che è quello
digitale in senso stretto cioè noi
parliamo da un
punto di vista euro centrico
ma non tutto il mondo alle stesse
possibilità di accedere alle possibilità
digitale appuntano ai mezzi di dis ha
quindi bisognerebbe anche lavorare in
quel senso li cioè rendere la voce
pubblica davvero pubblica lo sta
diventando pian piano poi si pone un
secondo problema che è come usare questo
potere ci lavoreremo già pian pianino
sentito 6 come sociolinguista diciamo
sei stata una cronista di queste
trasformazioni che sta subendo la nostra
lingua in particolare è da sempre 6
attenta e sensibile alla comunicazione
digitale
quanto secondo te è oggi influenzata la
nostra società da questa evoluzione del
nostro nuovo modo di comunicare
ma intanto secondo me occorre conoscere
una cosa consiliare un aspetto è
l'aspetto è la società la realtà che
viviamo e di conseguenza la lingua che
parliamo cambiano di continuo
benjamin worf che è il padre della
teoria della relatività linguistica a un
certo punto fa ricorso a un come si può
dire a un concetto della fisica
quantistica per spiegare la relazione
fra lingua e realtà e dice che le due
stanno in una sorta di in tengo il mend
quantistico il che vuol dire che nel
momento in cui noi cerchiamo di separare
la realtà dalla lingua facendoci delle
domande tipo ma viene prima la lingua o
nella prima la realtà è un po come la
questione dell'uovo e della gallina cioè
è una cosa lui diceva che occorre
considerare nel suo intreccio e quindi
in realtà la lingua è cambiata di
continuo il motivo per cui oggi lo
vediamo di più è perché questo
cambiamento ha subito un'accelerazione
notevole degli ultimi 60 anni
e come mai perché prima semplicemente
gli italiani non parlavano italiano
perfino manzoni no che ha scritto i
promessi sposi si sa in italiano è
venuto a sciacquare i panni in arno
eccetera eccetera con gli amichetti
parlava francese cioè la lingua della
cultura del momento era francese
l'italiano era ancora molto sperimentale
mettiamo così ma soprattutto molto in
vitro cioè non era la lingua davvero
usata dalle persone ci sono voluti centa
anni dall'unità d'italia quindi dal 1861
più o meno cent'anni cerci sono volti
cento anni di scuola ecc entrambi di
leva obbligatoria che costringeva i
ragazzino a mischiarsi quindi il
friulano che si ritrovava siciliano
naturalmente tendevano verso una koinè
una lingua comune e quindi diciamo che
questa l'iva comune era l'italiano o
almeno un tentativo di italiano ma
queste non sono bastati ci è voluta
un'altra cosa cosa che ha insegnato
l'italiano italiani la televisione in
particolare probabilmente molte persone
conoscono il mitico maestro manzi che si
occupavano col suo programma non è mai
troppo tardi delle persone rimaste fuori
da tutte queste innovazioni cioè gli
anziani e consiglio santo a tutti di
andare online e cercare i video del
maestro manzi perché io mi commuovo
tutte le volte quando c'è la vecchietta
che riesce finalmente a scrivere il suo
nome dopo una vita da analfabeta rende
anche l'ideale mentre mani di cosa
voglia dire avere la parola scritta ti
dà tutta un altro nata consistenza nella
società e che firmi con l'aics diciamo
che non puoi pienamente
partecipare alla vita della polis cioè
della città in senso lato non puoi fare
a pieno titolo a parte della società
questa anche l'importanza della parola
parlata senz'altro ma anche iscritta se
ti parli di hai parlato di di società di
città nel tuo ultimo talk per gli amici
telex firenze hai parlato di abitare la
propria lingua è un termine che a me
come architetto e molto caro no cioè
abitare un luogo uno spazio vuol dire
condividerne la smart lingua al che modo
l'identità no pensi che il nostro
linguaggio oggi rifletta la nostra
identità cioè lo abitiamo comodamente
con con facilità con agio
dipende da come siamo fatti se
rientriamo in quella che è stata per
tantissimi anni la normalità diciamo che
la abitiamo più comodamente ovviamente
sail il concetto di abitare la lingua di
cioran l'ho preso in prestito da lui lui
dice non si abita un paese ma se abita
una lingua perché in realtà la cosa che
ci rende tribù davvero non è il fatto di
abitare in un luogo è fatto di parlare
la stessa lingua e tra l'altro e
specularmente e la l'aspetto di
differenza di alterità che
istintivamente come animali ci dà più
fastidio è parlare una lingua diversa
cioè purtroppo istintivamente questa lo
dice telmo pievani abbiamo una parte e
xenofoba che reagisce davanti
soprattutto la differenza linguistica
così con un momento di questa persona
una nemica 91 un alieno comunque
tornando a noi prendiamo atto di una
cosa non non c'è da vergognarsi però la
società fino a oggi è stata molto normo
centrica è stata normalizzante vi faccio
notare che la lingua stessa nel 99 per
cento dei casi credo al mondo è
costruita sul maschile e androcentrica
perché perché siamo tutti i maschilisti
in realtà no perché la storia andata
così no cioè gli uomini hanno fatto la
storia le donne sono state molto spesso
dietro le quinte e quindi diciamo che
chi abita veramente bene la lingua per
la lingua italiana è il difensore di
sesso maschile prima cosa poi ci sono
tutta un'altra serie di distinguo da
fare però non le faccio perché sono
lunghi ma il punto è che ad esempio il
femminile piano piano sta emergendo
cambia la società cambia ruolo della
donna nella società cambia la lingua
molti hanno da ridire su questo perché
ma intanto perché credo che ci siano
molte persone che non si rendono conto
di avere un privilegio per esempio
quello di essere pienamente
rappresentato a livello linguistico che
fastidio da il maschile sovrainteso si è
sempre fatto così
voi capite l'iniquità di una regola che
aleatoria come tutte le regole della
lingua che se ci sono trenta donne e un
uomo dice di dire buonasera a tutti
questo è il senso e qui mi sono ancora
mantenuta sulla questione del vitalismo
di genere quindi maschile femminile si
sa io sono a favore della dell'uso dei
femminili professionali e tutto il resto
compreso almeno il doppio saluto
buonasera a tutti e tutte ma mentre
studiavo questa questione
una persona non binaria è venuto da me e
mi ha detto tutto bello ma io sono una
persona non binaria l'italiano non lo
abito comodamente perché l'italiano è un
maschile o femminile che si fa come ho
detto nel nel talk e chiara che possiamo
di rame la minoranza tiranno il momento
in cui una persona si mette a ragionare
sui diritti noi una prospettiva
democratica ma ci sono persone serie a
persone di serie b e da un po da questo
che nasce tutta la riflessione che credo
nei prossimi anni giungerà a maturazione
senti faccio un pronostico secondo te
questo esperimento linguistico
funzionerà andrà bene verrà accolto
dalla società parlante
allora io credo di no
intanto perché non stiamo parlando di
innovazione lessicale cioè delle parole
che è strato più superficiale di una
lingua e quindi a quello che può
cambiare più velocemente
qui stiamo parlando di morfologia cioè
del modo in cui appunto si declinano le
parole e prima che si tocchi la
morfologia ci vuole veramente un
cambiamento bros cioè ci vuole che la
maggioranza di una società senta
l'esigenza di questo cambiamento e credo
che al momento non ci siamo però molti
linguisti che in generale si dicono
anche contro tutte queste forme fra
virgolette inclusive
pronosticano che una forma come lo sva o
qualcosa di simile chissà cosa spunterà
prossimamente potrebbe diventare comune
nelle formule di saluto di apertura e di
chiusura quindi buonasera a tutti e
tutti è tutta una cosa del genere perché
quelle sono diciamo delle parti formulai
che della lingua e magari una persona
come si per dimostrarsi inclusiva o
accogliente con tutti tutto potrebbe
pure
appunto
adottare anche a livello più un più
ampio questo questa questa soluzione ma
che entri nella grammatica la vedo dura
mia speranza la mia speranza non tanto
segreta riposta delle generazioni mo me
io non so a voi ma ho una figlia di 13
anni e lei non passa giorno che mi
dicano no noi siamo fluidi cioè queste
cose maschile aster vinile e io dico
bello tutto va benissimo e sono contenta
però ricordatevi voi ragazzi che questa
fluidità non è gratis ve la dovete
tenere stretta perché nel momento in cui
lui arriverete alla maggiore età ci sarà
una società che tenderà a normalizzarsi
no russell ora portano avanti questo
progetto di fluidità sono sicura che
troveranno una soluzione linguisti del
futuro alla quale noi non abbiamo mai
pensato
largo ai giovani allora certo che sia
sempre
vera ti ringrazio per questa
chiacchierata è stato un piacere spero
che tutti voi possiate avere avuto
apprezzare no questa nostra bellissima
sorpresa che ti è stata fatta vera gheno
grazie grazie grazie